there are interviews that you remember
forever and princess diana with martin
beshear
is one of those interviews i mean she
dropped bombshells about her royal life
huge isn't even the word to call it i
mean this was so massive and now it's
even more scandalous because a new
investigation
just revealed how diana was tricked into
telling all
well there were three of us in this
marriage so it was a bit crowded
i've interviewed the princess of wales
so if anybody's guilty of intrusion and
access then
it's somebody like me lies deceitful
behavior
and a serious breach that's how a judge
now describes how bashir secured his
infamous 1995 bbc sit-down
which was examined in a recent expose
martin
asked me to make up a couple of bank
statements
et's obtained the 127-page report from
the investigation
beshear admits he faked documents to
show palace staff were being paid off to
talk to the press
investigators say bashir showed them to
diana's brother earl spencer to convince
her
to get ahead of the story i was shocked
and appalled
the judge concluded the bbc spent 25
years covering up for bashir and today
the network admitted it's quote
clear failings we are very sorry for
this
as for bashir he quit on friday in an
email to staff the bbc
cited health issues as the reason while
the 58 year old says
he deeply regrets his actions he also
provided this previously unseen
handwritten letter from princess dye
in it she writes she did the sit-down
quote without any undue pressure
even underlying that she had no regrets
this is what bashir told et
in 2011. i think she really wanted to
say her piece
and in a way i was lucky because i was
the person that she told it to
diana's sons released statements today
it brings indescribable sadness to know
that the bbc's failures contributed
significantly
to her fear paranoia and isolation
that i remember from those final years
with her harry took it a step further
saying quote
our mother lost her life because of this